Iceland's decode laboratories is one of
the world's leading genetic research
facilities decode has been running large
genomic studies now in fact for decades
and they really did pioneer the standard
approached where what you do is enroll
individuals into studies and make use of
their existing clinical records for
genomic discovery and this is now really
the right way to do genomic studies led
by founder Kari Stefansson decode has
been steadily collecting Icelandic DNA
to date they've run a must a hundred and
fifty thousand samples so we've got half
the population to give samples however
you actually got some
and examples we have made some
systematic efforts now undone but mostly
this has been trickling in over 20 years
it's amazing to see all these samples in
one place each one essentially the
fundamental blueprint of an individual
Icelander this is the concentrated DNA
of a person and looks like a little bit
approached I mean yes in this little
white pads that you see is enough
information to make command I mean this
is the sort of seek the secrets of life
is held within this but decode isn't
simply interested in archiving Icelandic
DNA they want to provide insights for
curing genetic diseases if you remember
many ice lenders are related and in fact
their DNA is incredibly similar
and it's this similarity that decode is
harnessing a population like Iceland
that is relatively more homogeneous or
that started from a modest number of
founders and then grew will make it
easier to discover the role of certain
genes because you don't have to sequence
absolutely everybody to uncover most of
the genetic information so this allows
you to look for the genes which might be
associated with
particular diseases yes because you
don't have this this background noise
you know there isn't a background noise
is less but we are not only looking for
the raw genes we're looking for genes
that protect against disease
[Music]